the latest on the looming threat of a
potential russian invasion of ukraine
and the growing american response as
ukrainian troops remain vigilant around
8 500 american troops have now been put
on high alert meaning they are ready to
deploy at short notice to nato countries
in eastern europe
yesterday with pressure building
president biden had a profane hot mic
moment with a reporter asking about a
different subject inflation and of
course he's also facing questions from
members of congress about all his plans
wija zhang is a questioner of the
president she's at the white house for
us this morning rija it's not easy being
president i think president biden is
learning that
anew this morning good morning to you
good morning the white house says that
members of the national security team
will provide two classified briefings
for congressional leaders today and
they're working on even more for all
members of congress in the coming days
as for that potential troop deployment
the white house says that it was always
part of contingency planning and it is
not in direct response to one act by
russia
i had a very very very good meeting
total unanimity with all the european
leaders from the situation room
president biden had an 80-minute video
call with european allies on ways to
respond if russia invades ukraine the
pentagon has ordered 8 500 u.s based
troops on higher alert to possibly
deploy to nato's eastern flank and some
american forces who are stationed within
europe may be called on to assist
it's not just a military offensive the
u.s is on alert for in a new bulletin to
law enforcement partners nationwide the
department of homeland security warned
that if russia feels threatened by a u.s
or nato response to a potential invasion
it may conduct a cyber attack against
the u.s from low-level denials of
service to destructive attacks targeting
critical infrastructure
so far the administration has not
imposed pre-emptive sanctions with hopes
that diplomacy prevails president biden
is also under mounting pressure to
revive his domestic agenda and deal with
rising prices
a recent cbs news poll found the
majority of americans disapprove of how
the president has handled the economy
and inflation
on monday when a fox news reporter asked
him a question about inflation mr biden
fired off an insult
[Music]
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound [ __ ]
that fox news correspondent peter ducey
tells me that about an hour later
president biden called him to clear the
air he said the president told him it's
not personal and they talked about
moving forward
ouija thank you